un procedimiento de mamografía utiliza
dosis bajas de rayos x para ver y
detectar cambios en el tejido mamario
las mamas de una mujer se componen de
tejido glandular y conductos grasa
tejido conectivo y vasos sanguíneos
una mamografía es una prueba de rutina
de detección con rayos x para las
mujeres mayores de 40 años o para
aquellas con síntomas relacionados con
la mama como un bulto o secreción del
pezón antes de la mamografía asegúrese
de limpiar sus mamas y axilas y no use
desodorante
ya que puede aparecer en la mamografía
de rayos x como manchas de calcio las
mujeres de más de 40 años deben
realizarse una mamografía de detección
una vez al año como un estudio de rutina
cuando no hay síntomas relacionados con
la mama primero el técnico coloca una de
sus mamas entre dos placas
especializadas las placas se comprimen
para aplanar su pecho de modo que la
cámara pueda obtener imágenes claras de
su tejido mamario es posible que sienta
alguna molestia durante la compresión
pero sólo durará unos segundos luego
debe cambiar de posición para la segunda
imagen que se toma de perfil
este procedimiento se repetirá en la
otra mama
los otros resultados de la mamografía de
detección se obtienen más tarde por lo
general en un par de semanas la
mamografía de diagnóstico se realiza si
la mamografía de detección muestra
alguna anormalidad o si hay síntomas
tales como un bulto en la mama o
secreción del pezón
durante una mamografía de diagnóstico se
toman imágenes de rayos x desde
diferentes puntos y se puede realizar
una ecografía recibirá los resultados de
la mamografía de diagnóstico durante su
visita para determinar los próximos
pasos